what's going on my name is Jay and in
this video I want to show you what is
NPM and how you can use it so let's get
into it if you go to NPM jegs.com you
will see this page and here's a little
bit of you know a very quick description
about NPM NPM is a node package manager
okay
so short description is reusable code
like people around the world are
creating this packages full of cool code
that you can use for your project v4 we
start using NPM we're gonna need node.js
because NPM comes with node.js and
that's why it's called a node package
manager so if you go to node.js org make
sure you go scroll it a bit and then you
will see some buttons that you can
download and then after that you can
install node in your computer after node
is installed completely in your computer
please go ahead and open your command
line alright and I want you to write
node - V hit enter all right and if you
see this like a version that means that
you have node in your computer and there
are showing you their version after that
let's make sure that we have NPM so
let's do the same thing but with NPM now
as we hit enter same thing if you see a
version right here that's because you
have NPM in the computer and you're good
to go perfect so let's clear these out
all right so now I'm gonna minimize this
let's go here for a minute I have a new
index.html file it's empty the only
thing I'm doing is requesting this main
J's file which is right here is totally
empty so let's start playing with it
let's create a variable here called my
date
and it's gonna be equal to today's date
so let's do new date and this is gonna
give us like today's date like right now
let's console.log let's make sure this
is working save it
let's go this is my page which is
totally empty let's reload the page
perfect it's working it says my day just
right here now I do not like this format
I want to change it so I'm gonna use one
of these node modules so let's go back
here and it's called moment there's my
favorite like if oh if I want to format
and I want something very very easy to
read like a very easy to read date
moment is my favorite so I'm just gonna
click here and here you can see is that
install any the only thing that is
telling use NPM I movement the I is for
install all right that's all we need if
you want to use this so let's go to the
command line again and before we get
started and you know we start installing
all these modules or packages let's make
sure that we are in the correct folder
which I am NOT so write down CD space go
ahead find a folder of your project drag
and drop it all right here you'll see
the path to that folder mine is correct
and I hit enter and now you are inside
your folder if you want to make sure you
can write LS hit enter and it will show
you a list of all the files inside that
folder that way you know you're in the
correct folder okay alright when I
killed cleared is perfect now the first
thing I want to do is this write down
and p.m. in it hit enter
alright and now this is gonna create a
very important file for your prod
is gonna start asking you some questions
like your package name right I'm gonna
hit enter the version I'm gonna enter
description I'm just gonna hit enter to
everything because I don't want to spend
time like I'm writing all this down but
if you're serious and you're creating
like a they're very very good parts in a
project that you're gonna share with the
world make sure you put this down
alright I'm good with that
yes hit enter okay and now if you go
back to your project you will see this
new file called package and Jason
alright
this file will have everything for this
project okay
so make sure you have this there that's
very important and now we are ready to
actually use NPM so let's go ahead just
go back here let me clear this all right
I'm gonna just copy let's go back I'm
gonna paste it and I'm gonna hit enter
alright cool if you see these warnings
don't worry about it it's because I
didn't put in my description and you
know there's a lot of empty fields
alright
so that's not a problem so moment if you
go back you will see now note modules
and you open that you will see moment
here which is what we want do not worry
about node modules right now if you
don't understand it there is a link of
the description if you want to learn
more about them but you don't have to
worry about this folder right now
there's another file right now it's
called packet lock Jason dot Jason and
this file is important because this is
the one that's telling every single
detail about everything that you're
installing so if you install moment a
moment they're telling you and all the
details about
package okay you don't have to worry
about that file right now but is
important that you have it there all
right so now I'm gonna go ahead I'm
gonna go to moment J yes and see the
documentation see how we can use it all
right so let's go here let me open this
a little bit more all right
I'm gonna click Doc's were to use it and
it says no J yes perfect that's what
that's what we did and what we're using
and here they'll tell you what you need
to do so we need to add this create a
variable with the require moment so
let's do that let's do it up here all
right cool I'm gonna save it and now
they're telling us to use this like
moment format all right so after my date
is my variable date is created I'm just
gonna put down here and try a new
variable let's call it my cool date
equals to moment and inside moment we're
gonna put the date and then we need to
put whatever format we want to let's go
back to the website a moment here and I
want to see what formats so we have all
these formats look and they're telling
us let me open this a little bit more
they're showing us all the formats every
single one so let's use something like
this I like this one it's very clean
people can understand it's just like a
double uppercase ll so let's do it save
it and let's console.log my cool date
all right let's do this
this reload the page yes so now we have
an error here is saying require is not
defined so this require right here the
browser doesn't understand what is it
like what is required so if you're a
beginner nodejs is a server-side
technology so right now we're using all
this in our browser and it's not gonna
work so for that we need something that
is gonna get our main j/s get everything
all the code that we have here bundle
create a bundle that way the browser can
understand we can use something called
browser file which I like a lot you can
use something called web pack too which
I love but for now we're gonna use
browser fire it's very easy to do it
right now and you can see is telling us
browser for unless you require models in
the browser and all we need to do is
install this right and it's using NPM so
let's go ahead and copy open the command
line again paste it alright so now i'm
browserify is available for us and we
can use it so let's close this and let's
go ahead and and scroll it a bit down so
here you can see how we can get our J's
file and create a bundle that we can
actually use so let's copy this let's go
here to our command line and let's paste
it MiFi is called main J's but if yours
is called something else just change it
and that's it all that's all you need to
do and it doesn't have to be bundled yes
it can be something else so let's hit
enter all right now let's go back and
see if browser if I created
bundling yeah here's a new file click on
it and you will see a bunch of code here
okay so you can see that we have all the
things that we created and then we have
all the code for moment and we're going
to have here a code for everything all
right so all I'm gonna do is go to my in
index dot HTML I'm gonna go and change
it to bundle dot yeah yes okay now let's
reload and now take a look now is
actually working the browser understand
our code and now it's like September
23rd 2018 looks a beautiful perfect all
right so now let's go ahead and install
this unique one right so let's go ahead
NPM let me clear this okay so ampion
install unique perfect now we have that
available for us so let's go the same
thing is gonna be a require here I'm
gonna put it here after them after a
moment and they're giving us an example
here from the array so what unique is
gonna do for us is that if we have a
list if we have an array and we have a
lot of things there and we have a lot of
a lot of numbers or strengths that are
the same and we don't want to we can use
unique so let's do it something very
very quick here so the variable equals
my list equals to this an array this is
one two one one one let's say for
example we're repeating a lot of ones
that we do not want so three three four
five six and then another four not four
and seven this is a quick example that
we have a lot of numbers here that we do
not want right and now we can do is
I'm gonna put my unique list equals to
because he's gonna be unique and then
inside unique I'm gonna just put my list
which is all this all right and I'm
gonna console.log my unique list and
let's see if this works so I'm gonna
save it and now we need to go and which
is um something that I don't want to do
you can actually automate this instead
of doing it manually but for now I'm
doing it manually every time you save
this Jes fire we have to go to your
command line and make sure you run this
that way this bundle yes get created
again with your new code now you don't
have to do it manually you can use a lot
of things to automate this that way
every time you save this file is done
automatically okay I'm gonna hit enter
perfect and now let's reload this page
alright and now we have an array one two
three four five six seven you can see
that we do not have all this wants and
this extra three and this extra fours we
don't have done so that's a cool thing
about all this packages and non modules
that you can use for your project and
that's it
thank you so much for watching half a
beautiful day bye bye